Hey youtubers it’s charlie, this is the
sherlock empty hearse breakdown that I’ve
been promising for the last couple of days.
What i’ll do is go through the episode and
include as many references as possible and
interesting facts about the story and the
production.
So it will be a little different than one
of my easter egg videos.
There’s actually a bunch of stuff going
on this weekend between new sherlock and anime
club so if you’re finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Since this video conveys so many details about
the plot and details of the story.
This is your super spoiler warning.
The episode is so long and there are so many
details, this video will just focus on the
parts of itI think are the most important.
Here we go let’s blow the doors of the empty
hearse.
Number 1 - The title is a reference to the
conan doyle story the empty house.
Both this episode and that book brought the
character back from the dead so to speak.
Doyle killed the character in his novel The
Final Problem.
The character was so popular that fans and
his publisher compelled him to bring the character
back.
Which led to The adventures of the empty house.
So if anyone didn’t like that there was
so much fan service in episode 1, remember
that conan doyle’s novel empty house was
essentially written as fan service.
Number 2 - Sherlock Lives Theories.
We don’t learn what we’re seeing is Anderson’s
theory until the last frame cuts after this
first scenario.
Let me know below in the comments how long
it took you to figure out.
I didn’t realize until the Molly Kiss, but
the weird dance track made me suspicious.
Derren Brown is actually a famous real life
hypnotist.
Sherlock tells watson later that there were
13 possibilities of how he could survive.
There’s a big debate going on in the fandom
as to whether he meant 13 ways he could have
faked his death or 13 ways he could have escaped
moriarty.
Most presume that he never suspected moriarty
would be so committed to his plan that he’d
kill himself to force sherlock’s hand.
All of the scenarios were filmed in broad
daylight with a full crowd of reporters and
people watching.
No one leaked any of the information, but
there were a few pictures that made it to
tumblr.
3 - Moriarty Returns.
Andrew Scott who plays moriarty appears in
all of the rooftop scenarios.
All those scenes were filmed during series
3 production.
Meaning he came back on set.
Early on people leaked that he would be part
of the new episodes misleading people into
thinking he didn’t die on the rooftop.
Later we learned that he did in fact die from
the gunshot, people keep asking me what happened
to his body.
Because sherlock and mycroft were one step
ahead of moriarty the whole time.
They had a government crew ready to take the
body into custody.
4 - Mycroft knew the whole time.
After lestrad calls anderson on his crackpot
theory the press montage let’s us know that
everyone ended up learning the real truth
about what moriarty did to sherlock.
Because both sherlock and mycroft were one
step ahead, they allowed moriarty to discredit
sherlock.
So once sherlock got rid of moriarty’s terror
network there was no more reason to keep up
the deception.
Which is why the press are just now figuring
out the truth.
5 - Mustache watch begins.
We see watson with the caterpiller on his
lip and mary morstan.
Freeman was actually on loan to steven moffat
and mark gatiss for 6 weeks to film the first
two episodes from peter jackson.
They had to film both empty hearse and episode
2 sign of three while production of the hobbit
trilogy was still happening.
So peter jackson rearranged freeman’s shooting
schedule to allow him to return to england
to film with the sherlock team briefly.
So his mustache was fake the whole time.
It’s kind of a sign that he’s let himself
go.
He explains to mrs hudson that he never called
her because he let a lot of things slide.
Including shaving his upper lip..
6 - Mary Morstan.
Mary is played by amanda abbington, martin
freeman’s real life partner.
And if you haven’t seen them together, they’re
pretty adorable.
7 - Sherlock on the cross.
The russian base sherlock got caught breaking
into was the last place he went to dismantle
moriarty’s terror cell.
That’s why he was there.
As a character he’s kind of regressed emotionally
because he’s been on his own for the past
two years.
The interesting thing is that the whole time
he carried watson around in his head.
That’s why you catch him talking to an imaginary
watson when he’s with molly later.
He probably did that all the time over the
past two years.
So in a way, even though sherlock left watson,
watson never left sherlock.
8 - Mycroft in the field.
The mycroft character in the books is much
more isolated than mark gatiss’ version.
So even though he complains it’s actually
a huge deal that mycroft came out to help
sherlock.
You learn later that mycroft is actually smarter
than sherlock. and that when they were growing
up sherlock though he was stupid by comparison
until they met other children and he realized
that he and mycroft were different.
Think of mycroft and sherlock on a sliding
scale of weirdness and intellect.
The smarter they get the more isolated they
become socially.
So sherlock is brilliant and can co-exist
with other humans.
Mycroft is a genius and can’t stand people.
9 - back to london.
The terror plot that brings sherlock back
to london got a lot of complaints from fans
of the novel series.
Mark Gatiss used the sebastian moran character
as part of the tube bomb plot and in the episode
the character is kind of wasted.
He just sits on the bed and pushes a button.
In the novels, Sebastian moran is like an
evil version of watson.
they both served in the military but sebastian
met moriarty instead of meeting sherlock.
So imagine what watson would have become after
leaving afghanistan if he had met moriarty
instead of sherlock.
Most of the complaints about the moran character
are that in the novels he and moriarty have
this really interesting relationship that
you never see play out on screen.
A lot of people confused molly’s fiancee
with the sniper from rikenback fall.
That sniper was moran and in this episode
moran is the government official that sets
off the bomb.
Sherlock calls Moran as the head rat.
It’s a reference to a holmes adventure that
was talked about but never happened in the
books, called the giant rat of sumatra.
It’s also a street near bull and bush in
west hampshead for which platforms and staircases
were built but no above ground entry.
10 - The tube is wonky.
A lot of people noticed that the plotting
and the maps of the london tube were all wrong.
This was on purpose.
The maps of the tube are heavily copyrighted
and no one is ever allowed to use them in
film or tv.
So they had to make their own maps that could
look anything like the real ones.
11 - Mustache references.
I know I promised to count all the mustache
jokes.
3, 3,7,6
12 - Johnlock for the win.
When watson tells mrs hudon that he’s getting
engaged mrs hudson is generally surprised
that it’s to a woman.
In my opinion she genuinely thought that he
and sherlock were a couple the whole time
they were together.
Which is hilarious.
It also pays homage to the subtext the fandom
has always read into the characters.
13 - The upturned collar.
The first time sherlock puts the jacket back
on is the first time the game is on theme
stirs.
It doesn’t play in full until he re-enters
baker street.
To the screams of mrs hudson.
14 - The reunion.
Sherlock disguises himself trying to find
a clever way to let watson know he’s alive.
This is a joke about the character’s master
of disguise persona.
The real joke is that watson doesn’t even
notice him at first.
The three diamonds on watson’s engagement
ring are a subtle visual reference to the
three’s company situation of their characters.
It’s almost as if Mary will be marrying
watson and sherlock.
Or marrying watson and gaining a sherlock.
Later in the episode when watson tries to
rip the beard off a patient it’s also a
reference to the holmes character in the novels.
The titles of the videos he tries to give
martin freeman are the same titles of the
books the conan doyle character tried to sell
that watson while in disguise.
15 - The headbutt.
Watson attacks sherlock with a headbutt in
one of the progressively dirtier restaurants
they get thrown out of.
In the original story, watson fainted when
holmes reappeared.
16 - Mary is a Liar - Sherlock deduces mary
and sees that she’s a liar.
There’s a lot of theories, but most of this
will tie in with episode 2 the sign of three.
When you see the date code on mary’s cypher
it’s may 11th, 2013.
And she says that her and watson’s wedding
is in may and she refers to a possible murder.
Since there’s a murder teased during the
trailer for episode 2, it means that she’s
probably tied up in the larger plot with the
villain this season charles augustus magnussen.
That doesn’t necessarily make her evil though.
17 - London Is Cesspool.
Sherlock’s voice over speech london is a
cespool is something the watson wrote during
the original book story a study in scarlet.
18 - Doctor Who references.
Notice the round things on the wallpaper of
mr shilcot’s apartment.
Inspired by the round things of the tardis
interior.
The code name of sherlock and mycroft’s
plan to fake his death was lazarus, which
was an episode of doctor who that mark gatiss
both wrote and starred in.
And there’s a tardis on the wall of anderson’s
apartment.
19 - Remember remember the fifth of november.
It’s guy fawkes day, who is remembered for
the gunpowder plot of 1605, which the tube
bomb plot pays homage to.
20 - Sherlock’s parents.
A lot of people recognized that sherlock’s
parents are benedict cumberbatch’s parents
in real life.
But if you notice the collar on his mother’s
coat is turned up you’ll be pleased to learn
that his trademark upturned collars are something
he picked up from his mother.
Sherlock holmes, what a mama’s boy.
21 - The final explanation.
Mark Gatiss explained that even though this
wasn’t completely correct, it was the most
plausible explanation as to how sherlock survived.
Since I’m sure there were a ton of lines
lifted from the books and other references
I missed write them in the comments if you
noticed anything.
I’ll be posting my episode 2 review tomorrow
after the episode airs.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
Just like last time I’ll be looking through
the comments on that video to include in my
episode 2 q and a video on monday. and then
a couple days after that I’ll do a new breakdown.
Right now click here for my episode 1 q and
a and click here for my review of the episode.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight!
High Fives!